(upbeat melody)
♪ So I wanna get a couple
things off my chest ♪
♪ Make a song for the people
that are trying their best ♪
♪ See the pics of my friends
on the beach just laughing ♪
♪ And I think to myself
yeah that's not happening ♪
♪ Spring break sounds great ♪
♪ Someone wanna pay for me to go? ♪
♪ If not, that's cool, I'll
be dreaming about a pool ♪
♪ That bank account too low ♪
♪ Let's go to the beach ♪
♪ Every year it's a bother ♪
♪ I'm so excited ♪
♪ They scream and they holler ♪
♪ It's 2,000 a head, holy shit, I'm dead ♪
♪ I reach into my pocket,
I have three dollars ♪
♪ Whatever not gonna shed no tears ♪
♪ My parents' basement's
nice this time of year ♪
♪ Can't say that I'm stoked
with no sun to soak ♪
♪ Because it's just another
year where I'm spring broke ♪
♪ Spring broke ♪
♪ Forget a swimsuit I'm wearing a coat ♪
♪ Turn a vacation into a staycation ♪
♪ This aint a joke, I'm ♪
♪ Spring broke ♪
♪ Forget a swimsuit I'm wearing a coat ♪
♪ Turn a vacation into a staycation ♪
♪ This aint a joke, I'm ♪
♪ Spring broke ♪
♪ People jumping in the ocean ♪
♪ Having fun belly flopping ♪
♪ Netflix is asking me
are you still watching? ♪
♪ Yeah I am, I'm chilling at home ♪
♪ Is it possible for me to
get a tan from a phone? ♪
♪ Sure I sit back bitter
at home and criticize ♪
♪ Maybe this is all just
a blessing in disguise ♪
♪ The hour is now to clock in me time ♪
♪ I don't have the sand
but I can still recline ♪
♪ Start that book ♪
♪ Finish that show ♪
♪ Eat my favorite foods ♪
♪ What else, who knows? ♪
♪ And just do me the
truest self I can be ♪
♪ Eating pizza buttnaked
every night this week ♪
♪ Maybe this isn't so bad ♪
♪ Invite some people over,
have a party at the pad ♪
♪ Spring break is overrated
that's the words that I wrote ♪
♪ I can travel the world
when I'm not spring broke ♪
♪ Spring broke ♪
♪ Forget a swimsuit I'm wearing a coat ♪
♪ Turn a vacation into a staycation ♪
♪ This aint a joke, I'm ♪
♪ Spring broke ♪